dum-dum-dum dum-dum-dum dum-dum-dum
um busy busy busy doing nothing doing
nothing that's the life for me
for when I'm doing nothing I'm busy
doing something something that suits me
to a team because I'm busy busy doing
nothing I find I never find the time to
rest being busy doing nothing I'm busy
doing something doing nothing is the
something I do best
[Music]
Christopher the very start
[Music]
is that okay
[Music]
shooting and action
Oh
I made you this my sacred wherever you
may go they will remind you
a woozle at work is going to eat him for
breakfast if we don't get them to him
who's let work we'll eat him for
breakfast
Christopher Robin said we should go
north
Christopher Robin said we should go
north
I believe North is the way Christopher
told us that we should go
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
take a
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
three two one action
[Music]
set okay shooting and action
[Music]
[Music]
Thanks
please clear gutters and background
action
[Applause]
[Music]
yes the most efficient thing to do would
be to lose the efficiency Department Wow
yes we can't do without an efficient car
but can we not hold on tight all right
ah well it's all laid out in my papers
rather detailed so hold on tight
Robin Robin
[Applause]
[Applause]
you